hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
the air on flash Q&A this week what lots
of stuff happening just because we're
getting so close to the finale including
the first reveal of what katanas costume
is going to look like there's also some
news about the spin-off show supposedly
Victor Garber did an interview where he
revealed that it would premiere sometime
in January and it was going straight to
series there hasn't been any
confirmation on that but that is in line
with a lot of the rumors we've been
hearing about the show so what they
might end up doing is premiering the
spin-off series with the back half of
arrow in the flash meaning that as we
get the last 10 or 13 episodes of arrow
in the flash next season they'll also
air the episodes of the spin-off series
they said they haven't shot the pilot
yet but supposedly the cast has gotten
together so hopefully they'll have like
a promo ready for the finale of the
flash or arrow comic-con is like just
around the corner so they'll probably
have some more news around that time so
no questions here we go first one Rose
Lily asks if Barry created Gideon why is
the AI helping wells well there's two
ways to look at this one is that the AI
was lying to Barry when it said that he
created it or to the reverse-flash stole
it from Barry in the future the actor
that played a Ubar thon is going to be
back before the end of the series so
what I'm hoping is is they do like a
flash forward and we get some of a bar
thoughts backstory in this last episode
he said nothing is forgiven it you know
implying that the flash did something to
slight the reverse flash or something to
harm him that seems like something they
would eventually show us before the
season finale next question para asks is
it possible for Barry to time travel to
the future and find that Caitlyn is
killer frost or Cisco as the vibe so
you're wondering like if Barry's going
to see a future where everything's gone
crazy and in there bunch of
supervillains running around no I don't
think that's going to happen if they're
going to end up being more like they are
in the comics like with their
superpowers or super tech in the case of
Cisco I think that they would show us
that in present-day first I do think
we'll see flash forwards like Barry
probably will time travel into the
future at some point meet you know maybe
in season 2 but I don't think they'll go
full terminator where you see like the
post-apocalyptic wasteland like the the
dark alternate future if something goes
wrong danielle panabaker did say that
she had a flashback
in last week's episode that showed a
colder version of Caitlyn and that was
going to be like a killer frost type
joke but supposedly it got cut from the
episode next question arpit Roy asks how
does the fake Harrison wells Hannibal
Bates past the superconductor shield
well so if you remember the shield was
just designed to keep people moving at
SuperSpeed out so anybody who wasn't a
speedster could pass through so
metahumans regular people anybody it
wasn't that he was vibrating his way
through and like he literally just
stepped through as if you were stepping
through a doorway next question Li Wu
asks I don't get the whole timeline
stuff so just to give like a broad
explanation you're probably talking
about the alternate timeline I'm just
going to do like a real quick once-over
for what's going on with the series so
what you have is is a bar Thawne from
the 25th century going back in time to
bury as a child to try and kill him to
prevent him from becoming the flash
future berry from 20-24 learns about it
goes back to fight him that night
prevents him from killing young Barry as
a consolation a berth on kills Barry's
mother then gets stuck that nights about
15 years before present day on the show
which is also about 10 years before the
crisis in the newspaper so in the
original timeline you know before the
show started the flash became the flash
around 2020 and then four years after
that they had the big crisis a bar
changed that so we're already in like
the second time line then there's the
third time line created when Barry time
traveled earlier this season the one
where Cisco died Barry went back in time
that week altered events so that Cisco
did not die but like eobard thawne said
if you try to change the past to avert a
disaster time will find a way to replace
that disaster with something just as bad
that's like the show's way of explaining
why Barry just doesn't time travel all
the time so hopefully that helps a
little bit the alternate timeline the
one that Cisco is remembering isn't
going to merge with the present timeline
or anything like that they're just going
to keep remembering it next question
sci-fi and banter asks is it possible
for Barry to go back in time to prevent
Oliver from joining the league or will
that create some kind of paradox that
will make everything else worse well I
mean I kind of answer that like a little
bit in the last question but no the
reason why I don't think that the flash
is just going to change time in a race
half a season of arrow is because that
would be a huge WTF from the writers
room he'd be like a giant middle finger
to all of us that have been watching
arrow for the last six months like
saying hey all this stuff we had these
characters do that doesn't matter we
just wiped it clean that would be like
the laziest writing you could possibly
do so whatever ends up happening with
Oliver I think they'll resolve that on
arrow he does team up with the flash but
we don't know if league Oliver here is
still brainwashed or if he's been fixed
and he just happens to be wearing that
costume still right now unlike the list
of like big questions that need to be
answered in the next couple of episodes
that's still like really high on the
list next question Jessica asks so Barry
in the reverse-flash both went back in
time did future flash go back to his
timeline or is he still in the past
trapped like the reverse flash that's a
that's a really good question i saw a
lot of you asking that what happened to
future Barry that went back to stop
young Barry from being killed the
simplest explanation is is that he was
erased when they changed the past when
Nora Allen died because in the original
timeline Barry just grew up and became
the flash in 2020 so short answer that
future Barry ceased to exist the minute
Nora Allen died next question pork
master asks when did they reference
Hawkgirl so she was in the future
newspaper when they were talking about
the crisis you know whenever they give
the big Justice League shoutout but for
those asking about that future newspaper
especially like the waynetech merger
Justice League there are some things
that they can do on the show some things
that they will never be able to do so
you just have to remember that the
sometimes when they do Easter eggs like
that they're just winks and sometimes
they're actually setting something up
how girl we know is in the spin-off so
that's you know more teeing something up
batman superman wonder woman probably
never going to be on the flash or arrow
i don't think that they would ever do
justice league or DC would even let them
do justice league if it meant breaky
cannon like that if they do justice
league in the future it'll it'll
probably just be as a turn of phrase
like they'll just referenced the Justice
League the spin-off show will be like a
proto version of the Justice League
interestingly enough they still have not
settled on a final title for that yet
even though legends of tomorrow is like
the rumored working title I don't think
that's what it's actually gonna end up
being next question nado
asks does this mean that there's not
going to be Talia and future seasons I'm
assuming you're talking about the League
of Assassins Oliver Queen Nyssa art no
it doesn't mean she won't ever be on the
show it just means that Nyssa is always
going to be like the top tier sister the
producers did a Q&A a while ago where
people were asking him about about Talia
al Ghul they're like does she exist in
this universe they said well she doesn't
not exist they just haven't decided how
they want to integrate her when they do
eventually mention her or show her she's
always going to be a fringe thing
Katrina law is going to be like the
go-to actress so if there's like a major
arc involving the League of Assassins or
one of the daughters of racial it's
always going to be based on mrs.
character the practical reason for doing
that is that it doesn't cause them to
step on a lot of Batman canon toes as
much as they change from the comics they
still try to honor to the source
material next question renan asks is
that katana or chess higher in next
week's promo that that is katana
straight out of the comics like right
off the page there's a few things they
have to explain like they have to
explain how she ended up in that comic
book costume all we know of her in the
flashbacks are that she has some skills
and she uses a blade what I think
happened is they intended to do like a
big katana arc and the actress just
wasn't available so you get to this big
finale moment where they're like here's
katana from the comic books and you're
like wait where's she been this whole
time how did she get in that costume
where did it come from there's only two
episodes left so we'll probably find out
what's going on with that costume next
week next question go revive yourself
asks why can't Argus just flatten Nanda
Parbat with missiles and get Oliver back
that hasn't been addressed actually Marc
Guggenheim did address it on his tumblr
he said if they did that there wouldn't
be a story he was kind of half joking
it's the same reason why Barry can't
just come in and fix all of arrows
problems for itself that there wouldn't
be a TV show if they did that so you
have to watch with like a certain
suspension of disbelief like these
characters are going to solve their own
problems every once in a while they
might get some consulting help from Team
flash if you want to get like really
technical with the Argus stuff you could
say that Amanda Waller is busy with
something else I have a feeling when
they bring damien dark on the show next
season or even at the end of this season
they'll we've him in and blame a lot of
the larger
problems that have been happening to the
characters on him like they've already
tied him to the earthshaker machine so
if you're wondering why like you know
mega organization with lots of weapons
resources are tied up and they're not
helping team arrow more it's probably
because they're fighting hive next
question pesky onion asks why is Oliver
blowing up Starling I assume you're
talking about the omega weapon he wants
him to release the virus to kind of
clean the city so to speak clean his
past that's what he said he might have
ulterior motives he might be
manipulating Oliver to get rid of
something in Starling without actually
telling him the truth or option B he
could be completely genuine wipe your
previous life clean so that you can
become someone new don't worry though
there can be no you know mega weapons
story line without five or six shocking
twists before the finale so we'll
probably get some more information
that'll add some more context as to why
Oliver has to do this to Starling thank
you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do I know there's been a whole bunch
of big news going on lately right now if
you ever wanted to see what it looks
like when like the online Hollywood
community takes a dump on someone just
look at josh trank on twitter i feel
really bad for the guy there's a lot of
rumors going around that I don't want to
spread about him because they could be
false but he left the Star Wars project
and now everyone's just like taking a
dump on him that's one of the really bad
things about leaving a big project like
if Zack Snyder ended up departing before
he made Justice League that's typically
when likes to do PR machines come in
insert you know pounding all the rumors
like big 800-pound gorillas speaking of
which I actually I just posted my
trailer video for Grodd lives that
episode it's going to be so much fun you
have no idea he's probably gonna be a
big thing in season 2 you can click here
to watch that if you haven't seen it yet
and if you guys have seen age of Ultron
i did a breakdown with spoilers in it
you can click here to watch that or if
you just want spoilers thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you